[Music]
you had a baby I did yeah life did your
wife yeah thanks for thanks for clearing
that I guess you know I don't wanna
boy-girl uh we're still waiting to find
out no it's a it's a girl my parents
couldn't tell with me for nine years
yeah they're respecting the baby's
privacy yeah I don't wanna you know so
uh so you have baby oh yeah she is five
months so we're still in weeks so she's
she's 19 weeks she's almost five months
so yeah I understand that you took you
got to take time off this summer to be
yeah with your wife and the newborn baby
which is really nice yeah well I happen
to be on break from the show so it was
great sort of perfect timing it was it
was great timing and it opened up a lot
of doors in terms of getting you know
acquainted with the little child and
becoming a father and also there were
things like Mommy and Me yoga that that
came up which I didn't ever think I
thought I would a not be invited because
it's called Mommy and Me yoga the or
work be working but I was seein me as I
thought it was pretty much it's for the
mom and the baby it's a racket
yeah yeah well yeah so you know my wife
said hey you're not working and you know
it says daddy's welcome or would I don't
know where it said that but true daddy
poster that explains it yeah so I I went
with her and it was I I mean I guess I
was welcome but it wasn't it was not
comfortable it was mainly there was like
no yoga anywhere inside it was just
women with their breasts out which but
let me finish why why not just leave it
I wish I could they were they were
breastfeeding oh my god it was just it
was traumatic
it was so wait a minute were there any
other dads no it was it was just me and
you you terrible terrible creep yeah
it's so clear to me like you're not
supposed to be there oh but they and I
thought I thought I was either gonna be
arrested or just you know quickly I
should out of the building but the woman
tried to make me feel comfortable by
saying you know she was like oh you know
welcome welcome welcome mommies and and
daddy and I was like oh thank you and we
immediately got into you know everyone
let's first engage our vaginal muscles
because I was like but then she would
look to me and be like not not you daddy
you knows a lot very respectful and I
said well I wouldn't even if I could or
you know thank you but yes and maybe I
can engage someone else's bedroom oh no
I guess the jokes you're trying out yeah
I had no I had I had to break the ice
I'm animus just babies and you know and
then it and then she stopped addressing
me and just carried on you know with the
talking very womanly know the feminine
power and there are uterine walls are
tired and and I was just sitting there
with my leg you know stretched above my
head and no one else was doing yoga
they were just breastfeeding and I was
you now look like a flasher or something
yeah
really skimpily to try to show you know
show what that I wasn't so stringy
yeah I think I think the uncomfortable
experience I don't have a wife
[Laughter]